he's one of the many people my life is
better for knowing and I might not have
met him if it wasn't for my wife who
befriended him and vice versa when she
moved out here first to California to
host a host of programs for Fox Sports
and cover the how about Susie starting
her career covering Leinart and and the
USC Trojans and Shaq Kobe Lakers Amy
angels when they won the World Series
good time that's how that's how Suzie
began her broadcasting career and she
got to know Bob Saget and I've gotten to
know him through all that and get to
call him a good friend and get him
calling into this show is the host of a
new podcast Bob Saget's here for you the
great Bob Saget how are you Bob
I'm good rich I'm so happy to hear your
voice Pop Tarts
that's the cardboard that it comes in
you know what Bob but that's a window
into your soul I think right there um
you know but we were just discussing in
our commercial break or just for our
YouTube and Sirius XM audience that the
the Chargers put out on their on their
social media feed in advance of the
schedule coming out what type of flavor
pop-tart their opponents would be and we
asked about do you toast a pop-tart or
not Bob I'll give you the floor
well I a blueberry is the only thing I
could eat and you got a toast it a
little bit it's kind of like eating
something that's not the cook you don't
eat frozen peas without heating them up
no I know that but you have sushi don't
you Bob don't you eat sushi i love sushi
but a raw fish is different than a non
baked pastry made of chemicals I hope
they're not a sponsor no they're not Bob
they are not yeah I mean I have honey
nut cheerios and that's all them because
a pandemic will do things to a man the
card word that hey you know what's
amazing I used to get Captain Crunch
cereal remember that please well
actually I don't mean to nitpick
it's Cap'n Crunch c.a.p ' and Bob as a
kid I didn't know I didn't know what do
you call that conjunctivitis when you
put two words do you know no but you can
maybe get it I don't know anyway you can
that's when you have your eyes dripping
and you don't need milk because I just
never mind anyway a watch I got a
Captain Crunch watch from sending away
for a sweepstakes so only thing I want
are you serious no seriously and I'd
like to thank all the people that got me
there the people that my mom for getting
the cereal people at the market so you
actually sent away your kid and you
actually you know cut because I remember
you would cut the side of the box right
there you'd have to cut the side of the
box for that proof of purchase right to
eat the whole damn box with the pop-tart
they don't care by the way that's the
first time I've used the word proof of
purchase since maybe I was seven years
old and sell pre barcode yes it's pre
park and there's no barcodes until they
open up and then the code will be nine
feet I do remember also that I would
just eat the cracker jacks and just get
that get the tree you know get you know
open up a crabs are completely sticky
that's right and then Hornets come and
now thank God the murder Hornets weren't
prevalent back then because they don't
got right for my hand and all I was
trying to do was get a little a little
memo pad like a miniature memo pad oh
the great Bob Saget Bob Saget's here for
you podcast is available we're all
podcaster are gotten right now so um
where'd the podcast come from bombin
well it was interesting because I before
the pandemic I was out doing stand-up it
was had a tour all set now we're ready
to go was gonna shoot a special in the
fall and then it all just came to a halt
but at the end of 2019 I went the same
thing as my stand-up people are arguing
everybody of all human beings all the
normal stuff you're hearing everybody
saying and can't we just all just have
some fun and can I make things brighter
for people and they were hurting before
the pandemic people were angry so angry
and we all know it everybody's saying
the same thing except for some of the
things that they're completely correct
and there is no other no other hand or
other side and so I was just doing what
I'm doing and I decided to do a podcast
to that reason I did two episodes in
to do so we could get the YouTube
component and then they went nowhere
there's no more in studio and I was
Danny Tanner I like freaked out I mean
did you disinfect everything did you
boil the windscreen on the mic you know
nice and they figure the same way I mean
you're you're in studio right I am Bob I
walk in every day like I'm Walter White
ready to cook my first 20 minutes of my
of my day is wiping everything down and
then I do the show yeah another one
wiping front to back right that's
important I have a face mask on my butt
right now
I'm afraid to sit anywhere I'm afraid
something I'll jump in a murder Hornet
carrying the virus but um virus jokes
but but yeah people do but they're doing
it in a different context it's not
making fun of it the thing I love about
your podcasts cover Bob as we were
putting it up while you were you were
talking about it is that it says at the
very bottom first podcast by a comedian
ever and then you you you bracket it
with these sort of gold leaf Palm D'Or
it looks like it's a Film Festival stamp
of approval which makes you believe it
is the first podcast by a committee so
you look at a podcast holy crap all my
friends have been there for 10 years
Joe Rogan created an empire you know all
my friends Bill Byrne and Bill's on the
podcast I'd love to have you on anytime
Bob you know that Marc Maron you listen
to Conan you know people that are just
fantastic at this and mine was meant to
be for real and especially after the
shoe dropped with being there for people
so I decided to have a phone line set up
and then on certain days of the week and
right now I'm on a Monday Wednesday
Friday schedule I just had Tiffany
Haddish day was yesterday in testing and
then tomorrow I'll be talking to people
and I believe on Instagram and Twitter a
number they can call and I'll tell them
I'll call them between 1:00 and 4:00
you're like the cable person it's
anytime between public-access I might as
well be the joke
Franklin show without without a video
that is a great now I have now I'm into
the whole zoom of it also I'm getting
like I'll be talking to Norman Lear
today that's amazing
brilliant wonderful man and and that
will be on unvisible on on the youtube
as we say they say no one says with me
but but the thing is I get to talk to
people and you do that as well and and
you're in a dilemma because here you are
promoting what you are what you wanted
to do was talk about sports what you
came here to do was and talk about life
I mean your good interview and you had
you know you know you know broadcasting
but here we ought to stand still and and
a lot of the calls I make I call up and
somebody goes Bob I didn't think you'd
call me and then he's stoned and I'm
talking to a stone guy for a half hour
and it's wonderful and then I'll talk to
someone else who's a nurse on the front
lines and starts crying she just lost a
patient to Cove it and and and I'm like
how's it at home and that she has an
autistic son who doesn't understand
what's going on and then I'm able to get
like that one little moment of happiness
out of her or just sometimes they want
somebody to talk to and for some reason
that gets they haven't seen my full
resume they feel safe with me and Wow
look man I know you you know you look I
know you work blue when you're out there
on the stage and a lot of people find it
you know jarring based on maybe not
anymore but look I mean you've got a big
heart and and a huge heart scleroderma I
know is obviously yeah a disease that
that is thank you for always supporting
and rich look your your your annual
events in order to fight this awful
disease you bring so many people
together you helped so many people you
also co-hosted the laughs a benefit back
in April that tries to help fellow
comedians deal with kovat 19 in this
world and everybody everybody showed up
man I mean so who who is who's the
person that you were around the most
when you started out as a comedian that
you're still maybe
with I mean when I began yeah when you
began who was there Jenny
when I was 17 when I started doing
stand-up and I was singing music
different comedy songs about bondage
that's how you came out of the box come
out of the box but anyway what happened
was when I moved to LA and I had gone to
the comic store and the owner Mitzi
shore said you should work here and I
was going to go to grad school for film
at USC because I'd won the student Oscar
I thought it was a big deal of 21 you
know those are really likeable people
who think they're stars and now they are
because the world has changed but I take
Garry Shandling was one of the first
people I became friends with and we
would go to his house in the valley and
would write jokes and most of them
involved you know my unit or his unit or
any many guys write to try to relate to
you your brethren and and then
relationship stuff and that was what I
did for many years and then Dave Coulier
moved on our sons of Mike binder but
then ivy you know I was thrown into the
comedy store world was Robin Williams
and Richard Pryor and I must have been
amazing most amazing man and I couldn't
believe they liked me they don't fake it
you know
comedians especially of that level
they're not gonna fake being nice to
some young guy who looks like you know
just a nice young man who then says
really weird stuff so there it was Billy
Crystal came and talked to me my first
night the Letterman was my host my host
Letterman was hosting no kidding and it
was before he did his morning show and
he was a you could tell that he was
going to be like one of the biggest
broadcasters of all time and it was just
a you know I'll never forget it and it
helped those character but being there
eight years that can knock you down when
all your friends are off going oh I'm
gonna go to a show
okay Arsenio see you
years when I get a show right and but I
remain in contact with a lot of people
on this this pandemic has kept that
going hyah Mendel have really he was a
guest on my show I'm min aus I have
people that are of note you know the
Stamos was the first because that's in
the Bible in the Old Testament must have
stainless first and then but other
really dear friends you know John Mayer
and Bill burr and Tiffany Haddish were
just on as I said in Seth Green and
Norman Lear and Jim Gaffigan and
different people that people I think
would want to hear but friends I'm
trying to make it conversations you know
well I mean that's the best part about
is if you want to listen to somebody
it's like two French talking I mean I
hope people feel the same with just
listening to us right now
by the way when I I did text you last
night because I did not know that you're
pinned tweet was from December when you
lost your dad and that gets right to me
cuz you know there's there's about four
thousand stages of grief because I lost
both my parents and both my sisters and
I'm waiting for others to go now as well
that's not funny but I do gallows humor
there's nothing else I know you do and
my dad was you know you were here turkey
bowling a couple years ago on a thanks
that's right and my parents were here
too and they were excited to meet you
and you know my mom who's probably
sitting at home right now watch and
appreciate you bringing my dad up and
you know you have a lovely mom and I
never touched her your comments about
your mother my mother Chris Brockman
across the way can't even look at me
right now cuz he's trying not to laugh
he's trying to not even look at me oh
man I can't make eye contact when we
talk about moms and Mother's Day is
coming up that's right perfect timing on
something perfect flowers I've been
doing a lot of tic TOCs I could do a
dance
[Laughter]
you will not even look at me right now
his head is a very I mean your mom is
actually beautiful
thank you Bob wants appendix over week
we get all the reunions at me would
understand I mean it's not her first
rodeo listening you talking about like
like this the pasta how about those
final nine episodes of fuller house
available on net for inserted they come
out June 2nd so people the closure it's
the closure in all nine episodes and it
ends really well people always say
what's your favorite episode and I
always always used to say the last one
and that was a joke but this particular
nine episodes do give closure for fans
okay okay I don't think your fans are
necessarily fuller house it's Bob I
don't see when they're waiting for the
Padres I think no no no no no Bob come
on now what would you say that there's
tons of fuller house fans after their
nine year olds watching do we have nine
yet we have nine year olds watching it a
fourteen-year-old college to be kids dig
it you know I care about your mom's
watching right now I wish we were on a
zoom or something so I could but but
zoom is scary because people crash into
them they just get in there I guess so I
guess I guess that's friend of mine
urologist yeah 800 urologist on a major
conference and some guys came in and
guess what they showed uh there is up on
the screen and I had to close the whole
meeting down so that ain't no way you
can't really be teaching about urology
and then actually show you know demos
Bob Saget everybody the hosts the new
podcast Bob Saget's here for you love
you Bob soon as you wanted to send my
best I love
another one I want her to know that I'm
in love with she knows I know that I
know that you had her at a low two Bob
you put that you take care of yourself
Bob be well my friend right back at you
at Bob Saget I mean that's the thing
with Bob you just don't know where it's
going or what's coming next cheeks hurt
oh hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here